I really like this movie I was probably
always gonna like because Nazi saw me
she is my kind of [ __ ] war film as well
I love that opening aerial sequence so
much can you tell me a little about
conceiving of that you know it must have
been hard as hell to shoot yeah it was
very hard to shoot and it was a very
lengthy very time-consuming exercise but
for me it was just about how can I get
the audience inside the action how can I
make it a subjective how can I make it
the first person how can I make them
feel like they're riding shotgun and
with these soldiers and you know
sometimes I don't really like one it's
because they sometimes it just be a
flashy end and they don't really have a
purpose other than to look cool and but
this for me was about how do I make it
subjective for the audience and so we so
I and to do that you need to sometimes
it's really good to do it at a longer
take and so really what was born out of
that and and once I figured that I
wanted to do that
we ended up at building this c-47 and
putting on this massive giant hydraulic
system called a gimbal which allowed us
to tilt the plane in any direction of 45
degrees so we had Javan our lead playing
boys you know as he's dangling and we're
literally vertical almost and hit with
throwing stunt guys down one after
another
hurling past him and you know there's
this practical fire that there'd
literally falling into and so they're
doing not only like a major stunt but
they're also like getting set on fire
and you like are insane and and you know
Jevons sort of scrambles out and tries
to you know he gets that gets the door
and finally he's held out into into this
Hellfire of like flak and tracer fire
and
and you know again we did that all
practically he's on a rig and we put in
VFX and afterwards but like that's him
experiencing what it's like to be upside
down and and then upright again and
upside down and operatic and you know
that's it was a wild ride it looks great
though yeah where's the struggle yeah
for you you get to play like we've seen
you play villainous before but this is
like you're playing like the meanest
Nazi in the movie which is a pretty
special kind of evil
it's it's beyond evil yeah it is pure
that it's the essence of evil right but
I know you always say Jovan who plays
boys is the lead totally disagree
I think it's me as a true villain yes uh
okay I've done a couple of innings one
of the reasons why I like villains is
because it's just more fun I love my job
it's it's one representing on passion
oils I wouldn't be traveling so much and
being away from my family so it needs to
make sense to make sense you know in
every sense of life but why why a Nazi
why I want to I don't want to portray
the the evil the evils people in the
world in the history of mankind because
I may only be able to do this once and I
may only be able to do it once where he
actually becomes a monster and I think
that's pretty fun I think that's pretty
awesome you know and I wanted to work
with Julius we had a meaning in nine
months in advance and we totally
connected we like the same things that's
not necessarily a good thing haha but
but you know when you're collaborating
you need different right opinions and
you need to struggle but it was so
effortless and was so organic because
she did something that you as an actor
appreciate the most he gave you the
freedom to give all which is the most
important thing and he gave me the
self-confidence to give everything I
could and that's why we were so good
friends all of us now you know
like a team I hope we can make another
film again in many many years with the
same crew and cost because you know it
was wonderful to become a literal
monster in your face as a situation so
like what was that to shoot with did you
have like some kind of green mask oh oh
that was five hours of make every single
day five hours of makeup and then a
12-hour workday afterwards so that was
that summer of 2017 no Julius wants to
be maybe used to talk about it I guess I
look I I like to keep everything as
practical as possible and you know that
with the special effects makeup included
and you know for me I'm selfishly I'm a
performance director and I love giving
actors the tools to do the best
performance and one of them is you know
making as real as possible and I can
look in the mirror and see it I feel
like it's gonna it's gonna give them
that extra 10% a new game set because if
they've just got the dots all the green
faces you said I mean it's they don't
know what it's gonna be there and people
aren't really scared of God and dots or
a green face I don't know it was scary
it we hide it so when we were doing the
reaction shots of the guys seeing it for
the first time the fight would have a
fight with a with an American soldier at
one point or the reveal we hid it so no
one saw it so we would get their angle
first while I revealed at that that's a
funny way of working because that's how
it should be you you have to inspire
each other right yeah that's great I
thought I thought the practical effects
looks so good but I thought for sure
that one had to be CGI that's so awesome
I think I think I have like I don't know
it's like it it's like a couple of
moments where there's negative space and
you know obviously we couldn't go
drooling into the real change so we know
that's how I work I'm total metric but
we are but we certainly you know I try
to keep it to a very minimum I mean I
always like the effects to do the light
work and like you know practical stuff
to do the heavy lifting but there's the
the
live when he gets shot the lip is like
this that was us testing and testing and
testing and testing how can we have this
up here and it affected my speech is so
much because we had a long discussion
about how does he speak now and he's got
no face and I ended up just doing sound
like that and we had to clarified it in
post most of it because it didn't make
any sense at all I was just a mumbling
German person you know it was a pleasure
thank you so much I love the fact your
favorite genre is nazi zombie films I
mean this one's kind of made for you day
you